I was telling long as a destroyer and he
was tell me listen to a podcast whatever
his name is and he was saying that Joe
had done this and this and this for me
it's so weird oh I secondly you know
what Joe took me on the road but when
nobody knows in the beginning when I
first met Joe he used to take Chris
McGuire rope
all right it was when they first met Joe
Joe was just starting to go on the road
I was going on the road on my own as a
feature act I really didn't have anybody
taking me on the road I remember I would
work with certain people but I would
never ask him to take me on the road
there were a few people who did take me
on the road with done Mike Todd Jordan
and returns and in my early career that
they liked me and then later on a
hell-like ah Jimmy shoe but when I came
out here took me on the road a few times
and helped me out and who else Paul
Rodriguez in the beginning you know but
I always knew that I didn't want to be
that guy I knew that I wanted to always
be able to do my own thing not just to
sit at home and wait for that beck and
call T them saying like that's the type
of person I wanted to be like I was
still at the Comedy Store every night I
was still I did all those Mexican roads
in South LA every single one of them
every night a week
that's what paid for my addiction but at
the same time not knowing I was also
becoming a better comedian because I
would go into deep terrain four nights a
week and then go to the comedy store
everything is hunky-dory you follow me
you know this there's places will keep
people come prepared to left and there's
places but it's a bar and you got to go
up there and blow your [ __ ] toe off
to get their attention it's like using
that what is it called the donut but
when your swing your swing batting
practice yeah it's a little different
you know it's it's it's really weird and
then you learn a fine line you learn a
fine line
after like five or six years ago that
you were a fine wine in between those
shows and how different they are and how
different you have to walk down the
aisle on shows you can't do the bar
material on stage and you can't do a lot
of the stage material at a bar
well it doesn't would it be hard for you
to do a a bar show now no no no bar
shows are easier for me well maybe one
yeah right it's 30 minutes it's high
energy and sylph mix it a little
compassion and just lay it on them but
it's got to be high energy so you stand
out from everybody else and you grab
their attention because of the bar the
television is gonna be on at the bar the
pool table is gonna be [ __ ] people
are gonna still play pool but that
sounds a lot like a comedy store said to
me no a kennelly store is a contract a
controlled savagery set it's a
controlled set when I go to lose lounge
I don't Wednesday night because I'm
gonna have three drinks I've bought a
couple lines of blow I also I get there
and [ __ ] Joe Diaz is on stage talking
nonsense it's a complete different night
I didn't come there to listen to some
guy talking in my [ __ ] eat right now
I went there to [ __ ] get drunk and do
a couple lines and maybe pick up some
dirty trick that's there so it's an hour
and a half of that so you have to
convince me that you're funny I have to
have to actually pay attention to him so
maybe a guy that's not as experienced
goes up first he doesn't really do any
damage because it's a different
environment and the open mic per se and
even the stage set are you with me I'm
with you I'm just why do you think that
like it just seems like that would be
funny anywhere why doesn't that relate
to like if you went like a comedy club
why doesn't it work Oh
because when I go to a comedy club
you're paying to go in there and you're
prepared to laugh that's a psychology of
the game when you go to an open mic
perhaps the people aren't really
drinking they're frustrating comics just
like you doing material it's when you
have a few drinks that you loosen up
onstage and open mics do not get me
wrong are a lot of fun I always enjoyed
open mics in the smaller cities because
it felt like the economics of fighting
for something and like I take you back
to three or four cities and I went it I
personally saw a growth every four or
five months because of that certain open
mic type pride in those small cities
cities like Houston Texas and he's like
Austin cities like Boston there's still
small cities that you would do comedy
yet and it's not as glamorous but you
get funny [ __ ] fast leaf a lot faster
than you would be in LA do you know why
because you get thrown into the Lions a
lot faster and they're different types
of lions so it's okay if you [ __ ] up in
the back of your mind the psychology of
it it's okay if you [ __ ] up in the back
of your mind
well it's interesting because it you
have a different judge every time you go
on stage it's not like the audience is
the same so that it that's actually
something that I haven't even talked
about before you can't even really it's
hard to judge your material because some
material works on some audiences and
doesn't work on others always but uh but
it changes every time you do a show so
it's hot that must be how hard to judge
how your material is doing because you
don't have a constant you don't really
have like a boss man I don't have any
workers getting better you have to have
someone come back no yes are you two
weeks ago well I know how I do was I get
offstage when I'm on stage I feel what
they feel uncomfortable sometimes I have
a really good time energy is energy and
what you give out is what you
back and you really learned that on your
own stage and people in front of you
with you in a play whether you're in the
music I can't imagine playing the band
like I did that thing you know what's
his name share with you my sang though
there's a goddamn comedy gene right that
was a completely different animal
you don't meet dog I over had a lot i'll
eyes everything when i get stoned just
like anybody else and i thought about
that night and why that anxiety came
from that anxiety [ __ ] anybody would
have got that I thought I was [ __ ]
like breaking down because I got anxiety
anybody would have got that that's ever
been onstage before it's the same in SIA
tu get when you get on stage as a
comedian now I was singing which I had
that meant I had a you know like people
behind me playing an instrument which is
another form of [ __ ] you know like
another constant I had never really had
that you never had concerns Anderson for
the tools or [ __ ] people whatever was
it that and I know you're an actor and I
stand up and you have probably better
memorization than most people but you
did stand up that night too so you have
to remember your stand up and you have
to memorize a song I didn't [ __ ] know
you have to do a story about the [ __ ]
song over I had no story about the song
I just want to attend [ __ ] around in
front of a bunch of rock people oh yeah
I'm just saying I'm writing a song is
tough
okay complete different [ __ ] genre
that's what jim Florentine is tremendous
at jim Florentine goes to these rock
bars and rocks got [ __ ] world
you understand me something that I can I
could do but I don't do it often I do
more of comedy clubs sometimes a theater
where you actually paid and [ __ ] come
see that specific [ __ ] comedian at a
rock club it's the same difference
but they're little rowdy and plus
there's a constant that's standing ooh
that makes to calm me a little tougher
right especially if you want to take
them to murky waters and go past the
hour